going
I've never heard of a cattle prod there
are stories of back rooms without
cameras where guys get roughed up a
little bit nowadays we don't need to do
that hello everybody my name is Brian
Stanton I'm a casino executive in Las
Vegas for Station Casinos I have 20
years in the table games business
watching and looking at game Security
today we're going to be looking at
casino Heist movie scenes and judge how
real they are
inside jobs collusion is a thing that we
worry about and a thing that we look
into there's been numerous stories of
dealers setting up bets that aren't
there or paying bets that aren't there
because they're in collusion with a
player things they're doing stand out so
when I'm Walking the Floor if I see
dealers turning their head and looking
where I'm at or where their supervisor
at they want to know where we're at
because something's going on
security measures when the system senses
a threat it shuts down and reboots
or for how long
three minutes and 20 seconds I've been
in a few older properties where
something will happen with a power
transformer power goes out in the city
if we lose surveillance coverage we stop
playing if we have no camera coverage to
the games we just pull the lids up lock
the games and wait it out we wouldn't
deal the games or operate without
surveillance coverage the system's in
lockdown all calls in and out of this
room are secure
again said it's in lockdown it's a very
Hollywood scene that is completely
unrealistic for a multitude of reasons
first of all their surveillance room
looks like an NSA skiff it's the nicest
room I've ever seen and no surveillance
room I've been in is that nice they're
not controlled by computers where you
could be locked out and couldn't make a
phone call I don't think there's a
scenario where we would be stuck in a
room I would hope that there's some
government agency like OSHA who would
protect us from being locked in a room
as a business practice we would have a
Hardline phone in every office and
surveillance would always be able to use
that obviously if power went out that
may go out with it and then we'd have to
use the uh old-fashioned find the person
and tell them what's going on
bringing in dice has happened I haven't
seen it in my career but I've heard
stories in that time frame of it
happening and they wouldn't be magnetic
they would be loaded where you would add
some weight to one side or another or
you would shave some Corners this is
very Hollywood the whole lighter and
seeing it flip so slowly from one side
to another I would hope my supervisors
would catch that right away if it was
possible and they wouldn't get away with
a whole lot of money because it's pretty
obvious
foreign
[Music]
getting that amount of bets for the
numbers that they kind of had over
everybody's heads apparently there's no
table maximum on any of these games
which is unrealistic as well I think I
saw a hundred thousand dollar Bet On A
Snake Eyes which I think 500 is about
the most I've seen is a limit for that
every bet on every table has a maximum
amount bet all very very unlikely and
comical for accuracy of casinos I rated
about a two
I would love to know if a mathematician
out there ever looked at any of those
equations on there and figured out if it
was anything card counting is not some
extravagant trigonometry problem it's
just basic counting second of all you
really can't learn card counting in one
day reading a book The General Public
knowing about it has probably been a
boon for us because people think they
can come out and do it and they really
can't
if you're gonna count cards you probably
wouldn't attract that much attention to
yourself you have the character in the
background flipping off the cameras
creating a lot of energy around and
drawing attention to themselves
splitting five
noticing that they're doing things again
he did split fives which you would never
do even if you were a card counter you
would have to maybe know what the next
three or four cards coming out of the
shoe were to make that make sense he
can't lose he can't lose the floor
supervisor in The Pit Boss talking to
each other we wouldn't need to cover our
mouths with a clipboard they're not
going to read our lips it would be hey
something's going on over there we're
watching it on camera let's make a plan
for what we're going to do about it
thank you
doing a distraction to escape doesn't
make any sense because they still have
to catch the chips out County cards is
not illegal unless you're using some
device to give yourself an advantage
smart watch or a computer in your shoe
or on your thigh that would make it
cheating a game but keeping track in
your head and knowing how many big cards
versus little cards are you can gain an
advantage and so it's frowned upon is
somebody's card counting in a Las Vegas
casino we simply say hey you're not
welcome to play Blackjack anymore your
action's too good for us this scene not
very realistic in in that regard one for
accuracy of how we do things in a casino
or representing how card counters would
act Ash flows from the tables to our
boxes through the cage and into the most
sacred room in the casino account room
it's not realistic to a modern Casino as
far as how you would enter it how it's
laid out or how the actions are actually
taking place you see the keep out sign
and then they walk in we wouldn't allow
anybody to walk in with a briefcase
nowadays the workers that walk in are
walking in with clear purses if at all
the count room is the most secure room
in the building there are procedures in
place for who can go in how they can go
in what they can do where they are there
probably in part because these things
did happen when they were run by
individuals or by the mob versus now
publicly traded companies they're
Counting
most they don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on I mean today I'm everything
looked down the up and up but you know
when you're paying out at the cage we
would count by hand and they did a good
job of how their hand motions were and
how they laid the bills out every table
there's a paddle to the right of the
dealer and they take the cash and they
drop it into a slot and it goes into
what's called a Dropbox and those are
collected daily and they're double lock
secured and security would come around
and remove them take them into the count
room where it's unlocked and the money
is just dropped out onto a clear table
and then the money is counted and sorted
and assigned to that table the guys
inside The Counting Room they're all
slipped in there to skim The Joint dry
they do short counts they lose fill
slips they'd even take cash right out of
their drop boxes did in a time period
back in the day where you hear stories
about these things going on well Phil
slip is just an order form when a table
game needs more chips throughout the day
as people get up and walk away and cash
out we have to replenish those chips and
you order a fill from the cage to bring
more chips to the table and that's how
you figure out how much a table wins or
loses in a given day and it was up to
this guy right here standing in front of
about two million dollars to skim the
cash off the top without anybody getting
wise the IRS or anybody the skim was
apparently a real thing that the mob was
doing to the casinos casinos are big
business so that it takes a lot of
employees to factor in the cash that
comes through and the accounting
paperwork that goes along with that so
it is a very busy room there's a lot of
people working but not busy enough that
we wouldn't notice somebody walking in
with a briefcase and walking out with
the cash it takes key access and there's
also cameras everywhere nowadays you can
spot these [ __ ] by watching the way
they bet like this guy he's been
lavender the chips 500 each with only
one little problem he's always guessed
right when things stand out you take a
closer look at it so they did a great
job of how the dealers are moving how
they're paying how they're putting cards
on the tables to how the supervisors
stand in the pit to even how De Niro's
character walked in and started to
observe things I saw that the dealer was
weak but he wasn't in on it it just
wasn't protecting his hand he was
lifting his whole cart way too high the
first thing he noticed was that the guy
always guesses right kind of bends down
to tie his shoes so he can get a look at
what's going on and where those angles
are coming from and figures out that
there's a cheater on the other side
signaling his buddy they cruise from
casino to casino looking for weak
dealers the way lions look for weak
Antelope using a device to cheat at
least in the state of Nevada is a crime
so you don't see that nearly as often
things like that used to happen as
computer technology took hold if it
wasn't for the device they wouldn't
really be doing anything wrong just
taking advantage of a weak dealer those
were the way we used to check the whole
card was for them to cover it up and
look for it nowadays we have a thing
called the peaker device which is a
two-way mirror that they Slide the cards
right into so that there's no risk of
exposing that card anymore
don't
turns out this guy in his [ __ ] Pals
they were knocking this place dead for
years I've heard a lot of stories I've
never heard of a cattle prod there are
stories of back rooms without cameras
where guys get roughed up a little bit
nowadays we don't need to do that we
have the Nevada Gaming Control Board we
have security where we would just notify
and do everything through a legal
process it's once they brought that
device into play and we'd notify the
gaming commission say hey we have
somebody that we suspected cheating and
we would hand it right off to them I
think the movie was done incredibly well
from a technical standpoint everything
outside of the cattle prod knocks the
clip down to about a seven and a half my
God I can feel a kick
[ __ ] amateurs this is a more
realistic thing that could happen and
has happened it's switching out dice
fake dice incredibly uncommon the Alec
Baldwin's character coming up as the
casino boss somebody with the experience
to be able to see hey the way he's
cupping his hand when he picks him up or
the way he's releasing them where
fingers are bent up to try and hide
something we have policies for that too
when a shooter shoots the supervisor is
looking for their hand to be open to
make sure they're not hiding dice in
there cheating on dice can be common
because there's a lot going on there's a
lot of players there's a lot of
distraction the biggest cheating scam
that happens is what's called dice
sliding where you would set one dice to
a number and then when you go to throw
them instead of the dice tumbling and
becoming a random result they can
control one or both of the dice and know
what the outcome is and either bet with
it or against it it takes a crew of
people someone to distract the dealers
someone to throw it another one to make
a big bet so a couple times a year you
hear of a casino getting hit with a die
sliding team again we have policies and
procedures in place that protect us from
that they always have serial numbers on
them we make sure that they match and
that there are dice there is some
security built into it
and he's up 18 000 census
sorry I'm kind of hit or miss these days
in this scene we see William Macy acting
as a cooler somebody who has such bad
luck that they put him at the table then
his bad luck hopefully rubs off on
everybody else unfortunately it is a
thing I haven't seen it in a long long
time managers throwing salt under a
table or pennies under a table because
somehow that was equated to bad luck
modern casinos I think have all gotten
away from that and just realized it's
all about the math
don't skip it
guys I thank you my pregnant wife thanks
you when he sensed that he was going to
get caught he said all right the gig's
up and he switched back to the original
Dice and happened to seven out using
your pregnant wife is a distraction this
is a much more realistic version of
cheating than the Ocean's 11 scene with
the magnetic dice on Switching out dice
I think this is very accurate I'd rate
it in eight
I feel like you should have somebody
from the CIA or FBI in here to evaluate
this more than me because it doesn't
pass the smell test for me on how
casinos work or anything that would
happen in a casino I think they say in
the movie it connects three casinos that
in reality are a mile apart there's no
secret bunker anywhere with an elevator
in and then the two security guards just
happen to be facing away from the only
elevator facing a door for no reason
your manager is probably reporting to
you now you have a little over 160
million in your Vault tonight
you may notice we're only packing up
about half that it would depend on how
often deposits are made to the bank or
whatever but we are required to be able
to cover any winners and losers now does
that mean we have to give it to them in
cash no we just write them a check for
it you know modern casinos we've become
increasingly a cashless society and we
have credit markers and bank wire
transfers
yeah in previous Clips we saw where the
count room was and then once the money's
counted it's put into a secure location
you can call it a vault if you want to
but it being this far out of the way
this protected like it's holding the
nuclear codes queue up the tape to the
robbery they installed on Tuesday
the images we saw those men robbing us
was a tape
I feel safe to say that nobody has a
vault quite like this one or would we
spend the money to inlay the uh marble
or Terrazzo or whatever that was with
the name of the casino in the vault that
seems like we could spend that money
better somewhere else I've worked at
some extravagant opulent places but
that's even a little bit over the top
[Music]
our directors of security our security
managers all either we're former law
enforcement or know them so they would
know when these guys walked in the
likelihood of an entire team of
criminals pretending to be Las Vegas
Metro or SWAT or whoever and walking out
with money I had a hard time watching
this movie when I watched it the first
time and I'm like wow I really have to
suspend reality to enjoy this a one on
how things in a real Casino look or act
or our run
cameras generally aren't at eye level
where you could spray paint them they're
usually up in the ceiling
first thought is that's probably the
most unsecure count room involved in any
casino anywhere those look like regular
office doors and the locks that are on
my garage or back door as opposed to the
locks that we would use how the casino's
laid out it's not very realistic the
count room is generally pretty far back
a house where it will take a couple of
layers a couple of access points for
someone to get to there wouldn't
necessarily need to be a security guard
in or in front of that door there are
security everywhere at the access points
to the back of the house that would take
to get to that hallway to get to that
door
I'm only gonna say this once okay he's
listening I am
what we would wear in the count room is
overalls with no pockets so that there
was no ability for anybody to hide cash
chips or anything you would wear that
uniform into the room and not bring bags
or anything with you so that you
couldn't take anything out of the room
main Booth scramble security
while surveillance did notice them after
a few seconds in the count room they
would have noticed them in the back of
house on their way to the count room
before that ever happened somebody's
always watching obviously once they did
notice them they said notify Metro which
is exactly what we would do
freeze hold it right there
I would tell the security team and I
think they would say the same we
wouldn't engage on the casino floor and
risk a shootout not a wise idea let them
get away with the money and we'll use
our cameras and we'll use Metro and
we'll track them down we usually can see
the getaway car see the license plate
there has been some large thefts
throughout history of cages and they are
very usually low Tech Smash and grab
hold ups and I've yet to hear of anybody
getting away with it armed robbery
that's more realistic to what I've seen
but overall I'd say it rates about a
five professionals always Place their
best through the croupier
two six thirteen two six thirteen
croupier is a term we don't use in the
states it's a European term for a dealer
he's obviously dealing European or
French roulette based on some of the
bets that were made thank you
34 no I'm sorry sir that's a late bet
how the player cheated is a normal move
it's called past posting the dealer
catches the past post but it's
interesting how he caught it because he
was staring into the wheel head which is
what we train them not to do they should
be watching the layout for those past
posts and listening for the ball to drop
and then glancing in he would have had
to have memorized every bet on the table
to notice that that was a late bet
there's been a problem
yes this group is accusing me of
cheating I want to be paid
the gentlemen and full when he does
notice the supervisor comes over and
gets involved and asks what's going on
the gentleman acts aggressively we
probably wouldn't pay that bet we would
use surveillance to see that there was a
late bet let's just get this guy away
from the table let's go ahead and pay
him knowing we still have to cash him
out so we still have the ability to
recoup those funds it's fairly realistic
from the terminology they use to the
Motions of the dealer to how the dealers
dress I rate this about an eight my
favorite casino Heist movie is
definitely Casino I think by Far and
Away casino is the most realistic
interpretation of what was done at that
time and how we've evolved to the modern
time if you enjoyed this video click for
another